let's do this let's bring in former
acting dhs secretary chad wolf is going
to join us as well at this time good
morning chad
good morning
we want to talk to you about what turns
out to be perhaps one of the biggest
lies
of the at least most recent news cycle
what's happened to at least one of our
border patrol agents and really the
agency at large as both the president
vice president and the leader of dhs
alejandro mayorkas have placed a massive
lie on one individual border patrol
agent and then therefore indicted the
entire agency over something that simply
did not happen first we're going to play
for you this indictment chad and get
your reaction
of course i take responsibility i'm
president but i was horrible what to see
as you saw to see people treat it like
they did horses barely running over
people being strapped it's outrageous i
promise you those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
there will be consequences it's an
embarrassment but it's beyond an
embarrassment
it's dangerous it's wrong it sends the
wrong message around the world or sends
the wrong message at home it's simply
not who we are
and it simply didn't happen chad nobody
was strapped nobody was whipped what's
your reaction
well it's pretty disgraceful at the end
of the day they have vilified the border
patrol these particular officers in
general it should have never happened
the secretary should have the back of
the men and women of the border patrol
of his law enforcement officers
instead you have not only the president
but you have the vice president as well
as the secretary
commenting on actions that never
occurred right we have the photographer
who took the picture who's come out and
said i didn't see anyone get
whipped of any kind and so
again it's just this attack upon law
enforcement instead of addressing the
crisis instead of talking about the
crisis that they have created that they
have no solutions for they want to
instead attack law enforcement for doing
their job as far as i can tell doing it
correctly
but at the end of the day there's an
investigation but when you have the
president the vice president and the
secretary talking about how they will
pay we've got to hold them accountable
that is not a fair investigation at the
end of the day and i think we all know
where this is going unfortunately you
know chad this is not the first time
that
joe biden has racialized things and
remember he was the one that said
they're going to put you all back in
change this is all uh used for political
theater um but it's also distracting
people when we saw the bulldozer you
know it looks like the cam encampment
has been cleared we know that the
majority of those people have gone into
the interior of the country another
thing we know um and you know so well
chad is that the people who got across
who are now in florida or somewhere else
in the country or some of them are in
towns and in in texas and and arizona
they are going to communicate back to
their family members who are either in
haiti or in chile or brazil or wherever
they were residing before and say hey it
worked we got through so are we going to
see more waves because of the way the
biden administration handled this we're
going to see more waves of migrants
well you're absolutely right we
certainly will see more waves and we
already have reports of another caravan
of haitians coming up from central
mexico
to the border look at the end of the day
about two-thirds of that population
under the bridge in del rio so about 9
000 to 10 000 will remain here in the
united states the secretary and others
talk about putting them in removal
proceedings what the american people
need to know is when they say that that
actually means release into the country
either you deport folks right away under
title 42 or you put them in removal
proceedings which means they claim
asylum and then they see a judge in a
year from now so
the vast majority of these folks are
being released in the interior of the
country and so when the secretary and
others say the border is closed and yet
9 000 get released into the country it's
a lie they're not being honest with the
american people and they're doing a
disservice they need to tell the truth
and they need to lay out a plan for how
they're going to address this instead of
just simply doing that failed catching
release that we've seen doesn't work no
you're right it doesn't work and they
call it something else they call it
removal proceedings which to any sane
american they say okay they're going to
be removed which is exactly what they're
not doing and then they yell about
something that never happened and let's
hope because of places like the fox news
channel people are getting the truth and
waking up to the lies that are being
told by this administration
chad wolfe thank you so much for your
time this morning we appreciate it